I don't know.
I wonder if the public versus the private punishment,
if that ever really works on Weirdos,
would it stop men from murdering?
I mean,
I don't know.
I think people that do it get caught up and when they would call crimes of
passion,
right?
I don't like that.
I think they get caught up in this moment and they just can't help themselves
and they want to kill someone more than they want to be free.
They just want to kill this motherfucker.
He said the deal without law shit later.
Right now I've got a rock and that dude's got ahead.
I need to connect this rock.
That guy's fucking hood.
What's this last public hanging in Kentucky in 1936 she is like,
how many people showed up?
Whoa.
Humans like that stuff.
We love to see it.
They love it.
Look at those guys climbing up on trees and shit in the background.
I'm going be that guy.
You gotta good look can't here.
There's one other one too is this is in France in 1939 said Guillotine on this
and you know what the guillotine that it wasn't a clean cut the first time and
they'd have to do it a few times.
Oh really?
Uh Huh.
Not always a good they had that.
You always hoped for a sharp blade.
Yeah.
That's the last public execution in France.
Yeah,
that's what it says.
What year was that?
1939 whoa.
39 whoa.
Is there a video of his as he was a German criminal?
I don't say shit.
Cut his head off.
Wow.
That's crazy.
Well,
don't really have the box in there to people's ago.
Joe Was your thing.
Yeah.
The United States is founded three people's ago.
That's true.
That's crazy.
That's what's hard to really understand.
How much cultural evolution has taken place just during our lifetime.
It's hard to imagine.
It's hard to imagine what,
what year were you born?
76 you could,
could you imagine if you had a time machine and you can go back to 1976 and just
wander around the streets and see what people were like,
oh my God,
you guys are children.
He don't know shit.
You have no internet.
You barely read.
I know.
What'd he do?
Sorry,
what's that?
There's a video of that video,
but let's say it,
I'm going,
all these people gathered around gather round,
fixing to drop the hammer.
Oh,
here it is.
they get them in there.
Get in there,
bitch.
The German ready,
and
we'll do that again.
Show that again.
Get them in there.
And
that is a crazy way to kill someone.
Yes.
Leave it to the French.
Well,
it's efficient.
I think that's why teen is,
this is what we do to machine we do not do is with our hands.
You see with the machine.